a multi-billion dollar duel is underway
to be the front door of the internet a
race starts today
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sure you know about Microsoft's
successor to Internet Explorer Microsoft
Edge but did you know that edge is
actually powered by Google and it's not
some sort of obscure connection either
the entirety of edge is built on
chromium which is the open source
version of Chrome when Google released
chromium they were primarily aiming to
help small developers and to support the
open source Community but somehow their
biggest competitor has ended up adopting
it themselves and this isn't a temporary
solution either in fact Microsoft has
already tried to compete against the
Google they of course add Internet
Explorer but the original version of
edge was also built on Microsoft's
proprietary engine Edge HTML and their
chakra JavaScript engine but this
version of edge got destroyed so badly
in the marketplace that Microsoft
finally threw in the towel and announced
that they too would switch to Chrome
since then Microsoft has even gone as
far as discontinuing the Legacy version
of Edge and that itself was two years
ago so it doesn't seem like Microsoft
will be returning to the browser engine
space anytime soon it's not just the
browser space that they conceded on
either they also gave in on the back
ended side of things back in 2015
Microsoft ditched windows and started
using Linux for their backend
infrastructure since then Microsoft has
even launched their own version of Linux
these two are likely Microsoft's most
notable concessions but this just
scratches the surface they also conceded
it in the smartphone space the music
streaming space the Windows 8 space the
smart assistant space and now even the
AI space instead of trying to push an
in-house version of chat GPT Microsoft
has decided to embrace chat GPT itself
from the get-go clearly Microsoft has
done a lot of conceding and losing over
the past last decade so is this the end
of Microsoft's Mega Monopoly are they
going to end up as the next Cisco or
Intel well the answer is absolutely not
Microsoft has been doing a lot of public
conceding but internally they are the
strongest tech company in the world and
here's why
foreign
Microsoft's approach may seem weak and
pathetic at first glance they're
actually making all of the right choices
here's the thing over the past 20 to 30
years companies have gotten into this
mindset that they have to be present and
at every aspect of your lives do you
need to wake up early you should be
using an apple alarm on your Apple
iPhone do you need to work out you
should be using an Apple Watch to track
your workout and at airpods to power
your workout do you need to text your
friends you should be using iMessage do
you need to video call your family you
should be using FaceTime do you just
need to sleep well you should be using
an Apple Watch to track your sleep this
trend is not just apparent on the front
end either these companies want to
control the entire backend process as
well if you're building a surface you
should be using Google servers Google's
compute engines Google's virtual
machines Google's Cloud functions
Google's databases Google's Cloud Nets
Google's VPC networks and all of this
should be going through to Google Fiber
basically if a product or service has
any association with tech at all these
companies want a part of it and you
can't really blame them they want to
constantly grow bigger and bigger so
they're trying to control every industry
that they can think of from
semiconductor design
thermostats but here's the ironic part
of it to truly continue growing
indefinitely the key is not isolation
the key is collaboration and that this
is precisely what Microsoft has come to
realize you see it it wasn't that long
ago that Microsoft also had the same
mindset of conquering everything by 2000
that hit two products out of the park
windows and Microsoft Office these
products revolutionize not just the
computer space or even the tech industry
these products revolutionized the entire
world permanently and this gave
Microsoft such a massive ego they felt
that they could conquer anything and
everything and to some degree this was
true they could put out the crappy
products like Internet Explorer and end
up controlling 95 of the market simply
because of their influence and control
this false sense of superiority LED them
to the email space their search space
the messaging space the video
conferencing space the gaming space the
music space and who knows what else but
eventually Microsoft reached an impasse
they kept throwing crap at the wall but
nothing was ticking in fact the crap
that stuck earlier was starting to fall
down as well Chrome was destroying
Internet Explorer Gmail was obliterating
Hotmail the iPod was humiliating the
Zune the PlayStation was killing the
Xbox and MSN Messenger well that was
going full on Extinct for the first time
in their history Microsoft felt that
people didn't actually want their new
products but maybe that was just bad
luck so they continued pushing they
bought Skype they launched Bing and they
entered these smartphone space but once
again they got annihilated their stock
had stagnated for 17 years their CEO
while a nice guy was also a meme and
hated by shareholders and a public
sentiment against Microsoft was worse
than ever Microsoft needed change and
they needed it desperately enter
satyanadala
foreign
if you are asked if you want to be the
CEO of Microsoft what would you say even
those of you who don't want the job
would probably be selling your butt off
after all you only need this job for
like 60 days and you'd be set for life
but Satya didn't even try to sell
himself to the board when they asked
them if he wanted to be CEO he replied
quote only if you want me to be CEO most
boards would decipher this as a lack of
enthusiasm and move on to the next
candidate but somehow Satya would end up
getting the job and he would spread this
humble mentality across all of Microsoft
his first order of business was
scrapping off all of the crap on the
floor he shut down dozens of sectors
like their smartphone business he
replaced the worst OS of all time at
Windows 8 and he replaced Internet
Explorer with Edge but all of this was
to just cut the fat on the consumer side
really he didn't even want to pursue the
consumer side the reality was that
Google Facebook apple and Amazon had
destroyed them in this market and unlike
Microsoft people actually like these
companies at least at the time so Satya
decided to give consumers a break from
Microsoft he basically made windows and
office free for end users and got out of
their way in the meantime Satya decided
to attack an up-and-coming Market Cloud
infrastructure at the time AWS was
really the only player on the market and
while they were excellent they were also
as expensive as iPhones so Satya decided
to focus his efforts on the budget blood
market and today Azure uploads AWS out
of the water in terms of cost in fact
Azure is up to five times cheaper than
AWS Satya also put aside Microsoft's
pride and started offering Linux options
because that's what Enterprise customers
wanted for many companies this was
simply an offer they couldn't refuse a
cloud platform from a a reputable
company that ran Linux and was
substantially cheaper than AWS was a
no-brainer but the cloud was just the
beginning Satya was intent on tailoring
Microsoft's products to the needs of
Enterprises a great example of this is
Microsoft's acquisition of LinkedIn
LinkedIn has become the go-to place for
recruiters and hiring managers Satya
also made the decision to ditch Skype
and build a new video conferencing
solution just for Enterprises Microsoft
teams and today teams is looking to
overtake Zoom at this point Microsoft
isn't no longer a consumer business in
fact consumer-based Revenue accounts for
the smallest portion of Microsoft's
Revenue last quarter for example
Microsoft made 16.5 billion dollars from
productivity and the business processes
20.3 billion dollars from intelligent
cloud and only 13.3 billion dollars from
personal Computing and that includes
Windows Bing Surface tablets and the
Xbox in other words Microsoft can shut
down their entire consumer business and
they would still be a trillion dollar
company but that doesn't mean that
Microsoft is giving up on or exiting the
consumer Space by any means in fact it's
the exact opposite
foreign
now that Microsoft isn't no longer
reliant on revenue from consumers they
can hit the consumer space harder than
ever before but Microsoft can't just
revert to their old strategy though if
they do it won't be long before they're
in the same position that they were in
10 years ago see the key isn't to try to
replicate the success of the iPhone or
Chrome or Facebook the key is to build
upon these hits and make them better in
fact you could argue that this is what
made these products themselves so
successful in the first place the iPhone
made cell phones better Chrome made
browsers better and the Facebook made
social media better the problem with
companies trying to expand it to
everything by themselves is that they
rarely make said Industries better the
Zune did not make MP3 players better and
the Windows phone did not make
smartphones better such products are
simply Alternatives that companies
assume that people will buy just because
it's associated with their given brand
or ecosystem this is basically the
definition of what Google and apple are
doing right now but as Microsoft found
it this strategy doesn't work forever
and that's why they're not making the
same mistake again instead of trying to
create yet another browser and convince
developers and users to switch Microsoft
embraced Chrome and addressed its pain
points they made the browser more
efficient and slashed its atrocious RAM
usage with 60 tabs open Chrome gobbles
up 3.7 gigabytes of RAM and a Firefox
gobbles up 3.9 gigabytes of RAM but Edge
only uses 2.9 gigabytes of RAM Microsoft
isn't hell-bent on trying to get you to
use Bing either you can switch your
default search engine to Google within a
matter of seven seconds
you also get the power of the Chrome web
store while not giving up the power of
Microsoft's classic products like the
office suite and the Outlook so you get
the best of both worlds Microsoft is
using the same approach when it comes to
Bing as well instead of trying to force
Cortana down people's throats they
decided to partner with something that's
already working chat GPT and by the
looks of it people are excited for a
Microsoft product for the first time in
a long time the new Bing was able to get
1 million people onto the waiting list
within just 48 hours and it's just a
matter of time until these collaborative
moves start hitting their bottom line at
the end of 2021 Microsoft was able to
overtake apple and become the world's
largest company but you probably didn't
even hear about this because Microsoft
didn't do anything particularly cool and
I think this is really the story of the
new Microsoft the background juggernaut
foreign
Microsoft isn't no longer trying to
constantly score winners product after
product because that's the loser's game
consumer sentiment changes all the time
and it's impossible to always be the
most desirable company with the most
desirable products but what is
sustainable though is associating
yourself with up-and-coming winners and
just trying to get a small portion of
that pie for yourself this strategy will
never yield any slam dunks because the
main product of whether it be Chatta GPT
or Linux will always outshine what
you're doing but at the same time you'll
also never end up like Yahoo or AOL if
chat gpt's time in the Limelight is over
no worries you have hundreds of other
winners that you also bet on there's a
saying in the stock market time in the
market always beats timing the market
most companies are trying to time the
market meta for example is trying to hit
the next GameStop short squeez is with
the metaverse apple is busy chasing the
AR VR and EV markets and the Google
thinks that they can hold their ground
against thousands of new AI options
meanwhile Microsoft is just investing in
the S P 500 it's not flashy or
particularly interesting but over the
long term not even Warren Buffett is
able to hold up against it and that's
why I think Microsoft is the strongest
tech company in the world flashy
products from meta and apple May excite
the Press but in terms of long-term
sustainable growth Microsoft is the real
winners but that's just what I think
YouTube realized just how well Microsoft
was doing comment that down below also
drop a like if you wish more companies
gave up their ego at least partly and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community tickets with your video ideas
and to consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
thank you